[Música]
porque cuando comemos un pimiento
picante sentimos como si se nos
incendiar a la boca como se alivia la
sensación porque el wasabi nos hace
llorar y qué tan picante puede ser una
especia vamos a empezar desde cero
primero que es el picante a menudo
decimos que algo sabe picante pero no es
un sabor como lo dulce lo salado o lo
amargo lo que en verdad sucede es que
ciertos químicos de las comidas picantes
activan unas neuronas sensoriales
llamadas noth josh sectores' polimodales
estos se encuentran en todo el cuerpo
incluso en la boca y nariz y son los
mismos receptores que se activan con un
calor muy alto cuando comemos un chile
sentimos fuego en la boca porque es
justo lo que cree en nuestro cerebro
sucede lo contrario cuando comemos algo
que contiene mentol el compuesto
mentolado activa los receptores fríos
cuando se activan los receptores de
calor el cuerpo cree que está en
contacto con una fuente peligrosa de
calor e intenta defenderse por eso
empezamos a sudar y nuestro corazón late
más rápido los pimientos provocan la
respuesta de pelear o huir con la que el
cuerpo responde a muchos peligros
es notado que las comidas picantes no
pican del mismo modo la diferencia es
que tienen compuestos distintos la
capsaicina y la peperina que se
encuentran en la pimienta negra y los
chiles están compuestas de moléculas más
grandes y pesadas llamadas alkila midas
que se quedan largo tiempo en la boca la
mostaza el rábano y el wasabi están
compuestos de moléculas más pequeñas
llamadas isotiocianatos que flotan
fácilmente a la nariz es por esto que
los chiles queman la boca y el wasabi
quema la nariz
y la medida estándar de picante de una
comida es su posición en la escala
scoville que mide el contenido de
capsaicina que puede diluirse antes de
que el calor no sea detectable para un
humano un pimiento morrón tiene 0
unidades scoville y la salsa tabasco
tiene entre 1200 y 2400 unidades la
carrera por crear el chile más picante
es una batalla constante pero por lo
general dos chiles son los más picantes
el trinidad' moragas escorpión y el
carolina repair estos chiles obtienen
entre 1,5 y 2 millones de unidades copio
que es la mitad de las unidades que
contiene un aerosol de pimienta porque
alguien querría comer algo que causa
tanto dolor
y nadie sabe cuándo o por qué los
humanos comenzaron a comer picantes los
arqueólogos han encontrado especias como
la mostaza en artefactos humanos de hace
23 mil años pero no saben si las
especias se usaban para comida medicina
o solo decoración una cacerola de hace
6.000 años llena con carne y pescados
asados también contenía mostaza una
teoría dice que los humanos empezaron a
usar especias en la comida para eliminar
bacterias estudios demuestran que los
picantes se desarrollaron principalmente
en climas cálidos en donde las bacterias
también son más frecuentes pero el por
qué seguimos comiendo comidas picantes
sigue siendo un misterio para algunos
comer picante es como una montaña rusa
disfrutan la emoción aunque la sensación
inmediata sea desagradable algunos
estudios han mostrado que los amantes de
lo picante son más propensos a disfrutar
de otras actividades excitantes como
apostar el gusto por lo picante incluso
puede ser genético y si estás pensando
en entrenarte para aguantar el picante
lee esto según estudios el dolor no
disminuye tu te vuelves más duro
se ha encontrado que la gente a la que
le gusta lo picante tienen la misma
sensación que los que no les gusta solo
parece que les gusta más el dolor
tormenta tus receptores de calor todo lo
que quieras pero recuerda cuando de
picante se trata te vas a quemar
agregue condimento a su vida suscríbase
a nuestro canal no se arrepentirá
suscríbase a nuestro canal para más
sugerencias y siempre aprenda algo nuevo
nunca